I'm temperamentally a very pessimistic
person I think that's probably a
function of my West of Scotland
upbringing but the great thing about
pessimism is that you're never
disappointed and when you're wrong
you're pleasantly surprised so I find
this a congenial working assumption for
life when it comes to the issue of
international security I'm on balance
pessimistic on the one hand I see
American hegemony or Empire waning at
the same time I see forces of of ethnic
hatred growing rather than diminishing
particularly in the Middle East but not
only there and then there's a third
issue and that is economic stability in
the war of the world I made the point
that 20th century conflict correlates
quite closely to three things empires in
decline ethnic disintegration and
economic volatility we've been through
more than 10 years of very low economic
volatility in most of the world and
that's had all kinds of benign
consequences it's been possible for
economies to grow that previously will
be divided by instability but it's hard
to believe that this low volatility
environment will continue indefinitely
and it may even be ending as we speak in
the sense that there have been since the
middle of 2007 ructions and financial
markets unlike anything we've seen in a
long time so if you take these things
together I'm pessimistic not only about
international security issues not only
about the endurance of American power
but also about financial stability and a
less night takeaway from history is that
financial instability can have all kinds
of second-order effects that aren't very
pretty so from this point of view I
think there are some quite ugly
scenarios quite near to us nearer to us
in time than a profound change in the
Earth's climate and of course there's a
danger that if we devote too much time
and energy to worry
about climate change over a hundred
years we could lose sight of our ability
to destroy ourselves within five years